one
hello everyone how's everybody doing
this
is rational science directly in
live from frankfurt germany we have a
great day today
hey guys yeah and uh
we're going to start as we usually do
we're going to do a review of the month
by the way
and so at the end of the uh or the
second half you can say of the
show we're gonna have uh all the
questions you wanna ask us you know
you wanna throw stones at us hey
uh make my day okay so let's start with
extinction which is what uh
a lot of people like to talk about in
this channel and uh
then we'll continue with a little bit of
the review of the month and finally with
the questions
distinction's a popular subject yeah it
is it is
um people i think are concerned with
extinction you know uh
in the last uh i i had a
one of the lectures in the past where i
discussed the fact that
um what is it in the last 50 years maybe
after world war ii uh the
number of books written on extinction
extinction of man right
and movies and etc has just
you know blossomed and the issue there
is whether
whether it's just a fad or whether
people have like a sixth sense that
something is not right
which is my take on that okay so
just to consider okay anyway let's start
with the quest
first question that someone asked here
we'll private with that
and the fellow says what is money
do you have your own definition uh what
is money well
uh money looks like that see uh that's a
hundred pesos in argentina
but you know i i went to a store 711
store in the united states
and gave them that and they almost they
called the cops on me
let's give us our stuff back they didn't
like that
so money is not money and i said why are
you arresting me i mean
this is legal tender in argentina
and um they said no they they would not
accept it
in argentina and uh this is what we have
here in
germany is a hundred euro bill okay here
in
germany and uh so every country or every
region has their own money
oh wait he's looking for a definition of
money well uh first of all he wanted to
know what money is so
the first step is showing what money is
today it's a little piece of paper
uh it's pretty strong you know you can't
even rip this
yes you know one day by mistake i put it
in the uh
washing machine unbelievable it came up
you know intact talking about washing
money
anyways i mean it's clothing
it's not just painting it's not paper it
used to be paper no longer
anyways uh money can be anything really
you know it can be anything but
there's uh there's a catch like today uh
you can use food as money you know maybe
you've got a karen your neighbor has an
apple you like apples he likes carrots
no problem you make the exchange
and so uh money is anything you can use
to exchange to trade essentially that's
i
think the best definition for that but
uh
after the global economy collapses
first of all no one will accept money
there will be no trade
and yeah whoever has food the last thing
you'll do in your life
is trade it away okay and uh
just as an example again in the uh you
can say in the paleolithic
where we still had neanderthals and
humans
neanderthals didn't trade amongst
themselves we didn't trade amongst
ourselves you know i mean our
forefathers right and um
and no uh in the uh in the jungle out
there in the uh plains
in uh in a setting where where you have
um
in the wild you know there is no trade
there is stealing there is scavenging
you know
uh but there is no uh no trade
uh not for food food is is the number
one thing yeah look at any wild animal
and that's more or less how we behave
you know you get a hyena you get a
cheetah or a
leopard or something like that when they
meet let's say the
cheetah hunted something as soon as that
hyena comes over
that uh that uh cheetah runs away
he's not gonna stand there and fight the
hyena he just lets whatever he caught
there and the hyena just takes it
and if the lion comes next uh well the
hyena has to leave it and
uh it's the lion who gets it and so on
it's the law of the strongest hold on
we're talking about money
yeah yeah but i mean you said you said
that anything you that you can use to
trade
is money but that's not correct the
whole point of money is
money in itself has no use besides trade
like using a carrot yeah that's that's
bartering wrong i thought that's what i
was you said you could use carrots for
money or food for money
but you can't that's not money it is
money definition because you can use
carrots no no you can use it but uh no
not necessarily because
uh it has an intrinsic value food that's
what makes it
but no no no but it is money because i
can also use
gold not only to trade but also to
bang someone over the head for that
matter i mean it has some use you know i
can use it as a stone or whatever so
there is some functions to other things
but then wouldn't money i can use i can
use uh
paper bills like this to light my fire
you know uh
like my cigarette you find you used to
anything but i think i think when we
talk about money we're talking about
something that we
primarily use yeah of course so
obviously when you talk about carrot
using
yeah but uh you could use you could use
it like if you have a gazillion carrots
let's say you're a farmer and you've got
gazillions of carrots
and you got a surplus you're not going
to eat them all well you do trade it and
that's essentially what big corporations
do they take all they sell it
they sell it and essentially that's what
they do they're using it as money
because the guy gives you money and what
do you give them carrots so
he gets carrots he's going to get money
for that so essentially
carrots converts into money some
downward down line you know
but my point here is that when the
economy collapses
and no other thing is important except
food keeping yourself alive
that's the big difference that's that's
why that's why i wouldn't
if i were using the word money i would
equate it only with things
that you only use for money essentially
trading
like if you can't talk about carrots
because the whole point of the theory
is that when money when money has no
value
carrots still do but miami's no value
carrots still do yeah um
carrots always have money but um
again uh gold can have value
in a different way than than for
exchange i mean we can go on forever
that that's why
i prefer to say anything that you can
exchange anything you can use as
currency to use
that word uh to trade uh can be used as
money
i mean you if fred flintstone accepts uh
rocks from the quarry you know fine i
mean that if he likes that
i can't i can't say no i'm not going to
allow you to
here's a few rocks give me your dinosaur
whatever
anyways that's what money in money is a
medium of exchange essentially anything
that can be used in exchange
then if it was another question or
another issue
yeah it's a question the events
extinction he's referring to you have
deduced from your reasoning will take
place in how many generations
well again here we do science and uh
that means that uh we're not gonna
give you a date i don't have a date i'm
not an astrologer
uh i i hope i'm a scientist i try to be
a scientist and a scientist is a person
who explains
in the case of physics you explain a
mechanism and
in the case of extinction paleontology
we explain
the extinction of species a mechanism
for extinction
and that's the sole purpose
at least as far as this channel goes
that's all we're concerned with
mechanisms of extinction how did the
dinosaurs die how did the archosaurus
die how did the
amphibians die we're interested how the
cookie cutter works yeah essentially
because
the reason is we're going to extrapolate
that to man okay so
we're going to say hey you know um if
these animals could not
uh overcome whatever got them
maybe man can't overcome you know that
same thing
but isn't that outside of science
talking about the end of man because it
hasn't happened yet
and again a lot of people say that they
say that's unscientific because i mean
if we're talking about explanations you
can only explain
the past something consummated something
that happened
other animal extinctions right and what
i'm doing with this and i'm saying
um i go to the future okay i'm looking
to the past i'm
i'm the martians or the klingons or
whatever that came to earth after we're
all dead
okay and so they go through the rock and
find uh
uh you know amphibians here uh mammal
like reptiles over there they find
archosaurs they find dinosaurs
and then they say oh here's this other
this we'll call it a mammal
and it's a two-footed mammal
it's he will call him human and he died
also he disappeared now how could he
have disappeared
well maybe he disappeared just like all
the rest of them and so
you do a little study you know you're a
klingon you do a little study you find
out how all these animals disappeared
you find a cookie cutter
and it turns out that man this animal
you found
in the 21st century still
he died for the same reason because he
couldn't avoid the same things that all
the other
animals could not avoid and that is food
what i'm saying is food once you get the
cookie cutter it's not that we're saying
i'm going to make a prediction it's got
nothing to do with the prediction when
we focus on the word prediction or
you know trying to find out what date
it's going to happen
then then you're in the wrong business
that's religion we're not
talking about that we're saying what is
the mechanism that
man cannot avoid that's the issue we're
concerned with
and i'm saying it's the same mechanism
all the other animals could not avoid
so i'm extrapolating it to man i'm
saying look
humans are going to die for the same
reason and what's that reason we're
saying it's going to be food primarily
food
and just very generally if you have no
food
i think we can you know god comes with
his magic wand to earth and wipes out
all the food all of a sudden for
whatever reason he has
i'm sure we're all going to die so it is
a mechanism that
guarantees extinction if all food
disappears
that's all i'm saying so it's not like
you can say uh
well i'm not going to consider it
because it's not a mechanism of
extinction
yeah if you wipe out all the food that
we eat
it is a guaranteed mechanism at least as
a mechanism whether you believe that
that's how it's going to happen it's a
separate issue
but it is a guaranteed mechanism that's
that's my argument the question is
if all the food went away how would it
happen
then you take one step further right
that's i think one of the next questions
yeah people want to know how that
happens and i'm saying
i'm not going to get to that point
because right now i'm having a big
problem getting people to believe that
if money disappears food disappears
is it a belief thing or just no it's not
i believe i'm saying uh
we produce the food and we produce it
only because of money in other words the
corporation produce it
uh for money for for uh profits
uh agricultural corporations right
they produce it they send it to a
manufacturer maybe it's the same
corporation for all we know
they manufacture they box it they cut it
they do whatever they have to do
they give it to the shipper sometimes
the same company also
the distributor he goes out there gives
it to the
outlets to the supermarkets and here we
come we are the workers
at the agricultural corporation we get a
salary
okay for doing our great work as farmers
or whatever out there in the field
and we go to the supermarket and we buy
the same food we produced essentially
it's a circle
and what keeps that whole circle going
the mechanism or the
system going is money is
uh essentially we're trading money for
whatever's coming to us
so we give money and we receive some
good
it could be a service could be a good
could be a
non-food good or whatever but the point
is you give money for that the other guy
gives money to the other guy and the
other guy gives money to the other guy
without money that whole chain
disappears
and uh we don't care if computers are
not around we don't care if
other things are not around i don't know
furniture house etc
we cannot live without food like we
cannot live without drink with
we cannot live without breathing those
are
essentials and so that's that's the
mechanism i'm saying
if money disappears food disappears and
i have people challenging me
i don't know if if they're getting ahead
of their themselves and they're saying
well how is money going to disappear
that's not the issue we're still not
there
we're saying that if money disappears
food disappears let's concede that issue
first and right now we don't i can't get
people to understand that a lot of
people say no that's not going to happen
we
some people say i'm going to grow my own
food that's one of the arguments
another one is saying well i'm going to
trade my
car for food you know they have all
these
these arguments and so they say food is
not going to disappear
so only because money disappears or some
media member exchange some currency
is going to disappear and i'm saying yes
once money is no more
food is no more because the source the
people who have to produce it
have no incentive to produce it anymore
so right now i'm stuck there and i'm
gonna be stuck there for a while because
uh i still don't see light at the end of
the tunnel a lot of people are still
complaining about that and also uh
you're welcome to ask questions at the
end of the show
regarding that okay let me continue here
meanwhile uh another fellow says
and he put this um comment it's a
lengthy comment and i think
he quoted it i mean it's got quotations
so i believe it's not his
but i don't know this for sure he just
put this up there and it's an
interesting comment he says in a mature
urban society the economic value of
children declines
he's going to say that we don't why we
don't produce children okay today
the new generations uh the z generation
i guess you could
in fact children turn from instruments
of production
into objects of massive consumption
children need to be supported much
longer sometimes into their mid-20s
in fact some people up to the 40s and
50s today
children cost a tremendous amount of
money with limited return
if any for parents thus people have
fewer children
birth control merely provided the means
for what was an
economic necessity okay so so he's
saying that
you know or whoever wrote this uh says
that we're having fewer children
and that birth control only provided the
you know the means now we
are able a woman that is pregnant can
get rid of the
baby or we use all kinds of uh
contraceptives etc you know so that we
don't have children we don't have the
the product from uh love okay
for most people family but you know what
that did was
simply fill an economic necessity for
most people a family of eight children
will be a financial
catastrophe absolutely you know who in
the city can
can really have a children i mean there
must be one or two people out there in
the world but
in the cities children disappearing like
you know
like uh like what like what could it be
it could be like
uh money from a bank like a fart in a
fan factory
therefore women have two children or
fewer on average
as a result the population contracts of
course there are other reasons for this
decline but urban industrialism
is at the heart of it he continues for
the first time in 500 years this
situation is reversing itself
first fewer humans are being born okay
which means the labor force will
contract
and the prices of all sorts of labor
will
increase this is what he's predicting
okay whoever wrote this capital
understood in its precise meaning as the
means of production
will be in surplus while labor will be
at a premium
the economic plant in place now and
created over the next generation will
not evaporated
at most it is underutilized and that
means a decline in the return on capital
put in terms of the analog money it
means that we will be entering a period
where money will be cheap
and labor increasingly expensive
okay so that's uh the argument i don't
know
um i've got a different take on that
okay
on the fact that labor will become
expensive
okay i think it's going to go in a
different direction altogether i think
labor will be cheap because we will not
need
labor we will not need labor and
manufacturing as
men are replaced by machines by
automation etc
we're already implementing a lot of uh
not only technology but also innovation
in the service world you know banks have
tellers that we used to have people
uh you go to the airport and you do your
check-in by yourself you know there's a
lot of people with cashiers you know you
check your own food
so there's a lot of um services out
there that used to be done by
like human hands and human minds and
that's no longer true you know you you
dropped out of
high school you could go and be a
cashier at the local uh
store and that little by little is
becoming a smaller world
and the new generations will not be able
to do that and so the question where
will they go
will they have to get a phd just to work
uh flipping burgers or
you know what's the deal here we got a
burger flipping machine now
believe it it's going to be more
accurate maybe maybe the temperature
everything you're going to have a little
robot
i think the part that really scared me
when i first saw it were the
self-checkout machines at walmart
yeah yes when i saw that that was like
oh even them you know because usually
all the jobs you don't really see the
jobs that go away
that was the first time where as a
consumer you see for the first time that
someone's job got taken away like if
if there's a truck driver or something
that gets his job taken away by
a self-driving car you never saw the
truck driver in the first place
so you don't notice it but as a consumer
if you go there and you see the self
checkout you're seeing you're like
what how about the cell phone car
there's no
at some point the shelves are shelving
themselves and you're like are there any
humans working here yeah yeah so we're
replacing man with machine in a lot of
places i'm not saying that
we're not creating other jobs but a lot
of the jobs that we're creating
again i've talked about this in the past
that we're creating a lot of
internet jobs everybody's an
entrepreneur going into the internet and
saying oh i'm just going to do
sell something information or whatever
and that's not really
in the same line as we had services in
the past where someone would cut your
grass or your hair or whatever
that that's real or distributed delivery
you know which still is strong you know
but those were jobs where humans are
required still
whereas when you get into internet it's
like you know
your own you have your own company you
you open up your own shop
and what what do you sell are you
selling
bananas are you selling uh computers
what are you selling no you're selling
sometimes information
like me here you know what do i do i i
talk
like a teacher yeah so there's a lot of
that
going on people giving information or
advice on how to invest your money you
know
there's a lot of uh stuff out there one
topic that doesn't get talked about
about
which is very important for this whole
corona thing
is with um necessary jobs yeah yeah
that's another one it was a big one
where there's a lot of jobs that like
you you always talk about the one where
like if you get paid to wave your hand
back and forth is that really a job
singing yeah guys is it necessary but i
mean on some level you know maybe some
guy doesn't kill himself because he
heard a song so i don't know maybe it
saved his life
i don't know there's a lot of you know
tangents but yeah but corona brought up
this question
of uh in german there's a term for it
it's something like infrastructure
necessary jobs something like that whoa
anyways uh yeah um i don't know
i think uh work will become cheaper
labor will become cheaper and one of the
problems there
is that with the devaluation of money
okay so you have money being devaluated
okay because governments
are producing more money to cover holes
to cover debt to cover
uh lately you know a lot of um
socialism helping people out that
because of corona et cetera
and so you know governments are creating
money and that's not only the u.s
government
every government out there is creating
money right now
lots of money what that does is dilute
the real value
of the worker if on top of that you you
see
companies closing down and replacing man
with machine
and a lot of that stuff going on you
know when you put it all together you
know the
the price of labor is going to go down
uh wait but that's not entirely true is
it because
if if the price of labor that still
must be done with humans is that there
is something
well there there is a lot of labor done
by humans
and of course that's going to continue
for a while but the
issue here is that i'm saying that with
the devaluation of money
uh together with the fact that we are
not needing certain labors or that
labor's becoming cheap and companies can
select who they're going to give us
i think that's a big big thing the
reason why labor will get cheaper is
because there's so many people that get
laid off
that there's going to be more people
clamoring for the same leftover jobs
and that's that's my point and so the
issue here is that that double whammy
uh will get to a point where people will
not
will barely be able to make it to the
united states yeah yeah
and people will be barely more and more
the point here is that
more and more people will be able to
will barely be able to get to the month
there won't be any disposable income
so you won't be able to go out there and
say i'm going to buy a car
no because fewer and fewer people will
be able to afford
such a luxury and so the market
for just an example for cars will reduce
that means that the company that
produces car cars
uh will have to produce fewer cars
they'll need less
labor and the cycle continues okay it's
just a round
okay so that's that's in general terms
what i'm proposing here
okay and uh just reminding people that
we do
let me put it over here we do extinction
uh 101 before we do 102 and extension
101 is
human i'm sorry um
past animals um animals who
died millions of years ago for mass
extinction right
and then we do humans so first tell me
how the animals in the past died that
means you're an
expert on extinction okay we're all
experts on man we know we know how man's
gonna die
some people say we won't die but where i
always find trouble is finding
a problem finding uh people who
understand how
animals died in the past see that's
where that's where you have to tell me
because isn't that because they kind of
chalk it up to
asteroids all the time well they give
you all these uh
catastrophic theories you know volcanoes
supernovas
climate could be you know it could be uh
asteroids
but the issue is that none of those
mechanisms
can explain selectivity and that's why i
always tear those down
anyone who comes with a catastrophic
theory has to tell me how mother nature
selected this species and left the other
one alive
not only on land but in the air and in
the sea well do you
don't you see the asteroid shattered and
it sniped exactly
all the terrain i know the way they say
it they use several mechanisms
they all use september one where it hits
and then the volcanoes explode and
the ashes make it rain do you have acid
rain for one
and that how did the animals under the
sea die you know like in the case of the
cretaceous the
reptiles uh well uh acidity and they
could take it into
sharks and the fish could you know and
so on and how did the
uh pterosaurs uh die up there well the
birds continue
flying you know the eagles and so on
whatever uh
you know this is what you can explain
and catastrophic theories cannot explain
that
and aside from that you know you have
this
nebular hypothesis so to speak in other
words you have this cloud
that surrounds the planet and when when
the asteroid
hit and so it blocked out the sun and
they say that
plants died well why did it kill only
the
conifers and leave the angiosperms alive
that's
you know you gotta explain that and they
don't elective
yeah it's a selectivity that's what they
what
a catastrophic theory cannot explain
okay let me do a quick review of what we
did this month and then move ahead
there's not much here i essentially
covered it the other day but
i'll go through it real quick okay here
we have it uh we have what is a point
well it's a dot it's a two-dimensional
uh
circle geometry yeah yeah where's the
exit
let me cover it real quick uh what is a
line it's uh
an itinerary it's not what you see on
under the red
it's what you see under the green
according to mathematics or in geometry
in other words it's not
a two-dimensional stick right or
or elongated uh rectangle no it's an
itinerary okay a bunch of locations
that's what
how it's defined okay what is a plane
well i couldn't put anything under the
green because it's infinite
right that's what they say the plane is
infinite so i have nothing to put what
am i gonna i can't put an infinite
uh geometric figure
okay uh what is a solid well again i
can't put anything because it's a bunch
of dots
and it's hollow all solids are hollows
yeah it's hollow inside see a cylinder
is not a cylinder cylinder is a bunch of
points
which is an itinerary and closing
absolutely nothing
okay and uh what is a circle well again
it's the same thing as the dot it's a
usually bigger but that's not that's not
what it really is that's the circle of
physics when we point and we say that's
a circle we think of you know
uh what you see there in red but what
you see on the right
right of that uh you'll see an itinerary
it's an orbit
that's what a circle is according to the
definition
of mathematical physics according to the
definition of geometry we've had for
2000 years so it's an orbit what is a
semi-circle the same thing but cut in
half
that's half an orbit i don't know how
this how the earth does half an orbit
but that's what a semicircle is
what is a sphere well once you created
that semicircle
that itinerary now you move the
itinerary around you
you you twirl it around once and you
create what is known as a sphere
a sphere is a hollow uh made
of dots actually locations that are
twirled around well without going so
deep
into each one like what are we just
saying that
they don't use static shapes exactly
they always use dynamic ones
right all geometric figures the word
figure
is uh misleading there is no feeling
figures yeah yeah it's like figure
skating that would be a good analogy
i can't point to a figure i can point to
the girl
doing the skating uh the location she
occupies and i say
is that a figure no that's figure
skating
so there is no skate no no figure in
geometry or mathematical physics and
that's a big problem because
people say well i know what a circle is
i know what a sphere is i know what a
cube is
no you don't it's a bunch of itineraries
okay and here's the rest of them okay
though the ones we covered so
let's go through those real quick if i
can get it up here there we go
yeah we're gonna go through all of them
real quick we have a square
okay what is a square well again it's an
itinerary and i don't know if you can
see there's a little dot going around
okay uh that little dot i put it there
so that you can see
something but actually a square is a
bunch of locations
it's an itinerary that moves around the
perimeter
known as a square in physics i mean it's
like programming you would use that
yeah if you it's drawn it goes to what
plus one x and then negative
one y and then plus minus one x and plus
one y and you do go right down left up
yeah and that's what it is it's an
instruction on how to
make how to construct a square that's
more or less like and it's a bunch of
locations
it's an itinerary what is a cube the
same thing
but you have remember it's it's six of
those
that build the walls and the walls are
you know it's like
the frames of of your window but without
the window
there is no window in a cube
it's just the frame and the frame is
just a bunch of locations
and itinerary so they have six of those
and that's what they call a cube
uh what is the tesseract uh or hypercube
as it's known
well they show what you see under the
red there which is a blue one okay
tesseract right next to the word but uh
when they talk about it they go through
that
monster there they say it's all these
cubes coming out of there like
jack-in-the-box you know just
pops out you know a thousand clowns
that's what it is
okay popping out of a box where they get
those cues only in their minds because
it's not what we have in front of us
what we have in front of us is that
two nested cubes essentially that's what
it is okay
and none of those is four-dimensional
which is what they claim it is
they say it's time involved in there and
you gotta imagine and of course you
cannot imagine a four-dimensional
cue okay that's a trippy movie of a
tesseract yeah
yeah i can watch that for hours like
it's like a screensaver
and then we have the hyperspheres the
same thing they draw three in this case
three
nested or yeah three three nested
spheres okay and what it is it involves
time
supposedly and what it is is a balloon
that's growing and they take
three of the frames of that movie or
three snapshots of that
movie right and they superimpose them
and they say you're staring at a hyper
sphere
but then what they explain is they say
well you need time
okay because that's one thing that i
don't understand they always add time to
a
3d object and make it a 4d object yeah
and why do you have to talk about
tesseracts and hyperspheres
if you could just talk about ordinary
objects yeah because
and is already a test right in that
sense because it's like one guy
said in in one of the comments he said
everything is four dimensional then
because you take a human
but who has three dimension you make
them walk and now you have time and so
or motion or one of those two and now
you have a four-dimensional human but
that's kind of what they say don't they
yeah that is what they say that's
exactly what they say they say that
because the cube moved
it now is four dimension
well temperature dimension we're gonna
get that in
in the questions that i've got uh i'll
get to that how hard is the tesseract it
might be
fifth dimension yeah you can add as many
dimensions you can add the dimension of
mass the dimension of temperature
the mention of color you can say what
you want then we're just talking about
properties
yeah because then we lose the notion of
dimension i'm going to get to that
because someone asked that question
yeah in fact it's going to be covered
and okay so uh well there was one more
i'll just
quickly go through it there was one more
i left behind that's the
taurus it's a donut they point to a
donut
but that's not that's not what they
explain what they explain is they're
rotating
the rotating donut and what is the
rotating donuts a bunch of
locations that are twirling around in
situ in other words
in the same plane right all around and
so
and then they also move the donut you
know they do double rotation they do the
the you know local uh location moving in
a plane and then they also twirl the
whole thing around so there's double
motion you
i guess it's a five-dimensional you lose
track how many
but like we gotta go to a bakery and ask
for some tauruses and stuff yeah
yeah this is yeah that's like a dozen
tauruses but i wanted to twirl yeah
i want to see it okay and so what are
the conclusions for
this uh just briefly math figures are
not figures
okay math physics only has itineraries
there are no figures in mathematical
physics
line circle etc bunch of locations
that's all they are
okay all math solids are hollow there's
not a single
solid i don't know what they use well
because
if they're hollow uh why do they call it
solid to begin with okay
second people are misled to believe that
you know yeah i know what a
cube is it looks like a rubik's cube
right and that's not the case
it's uh it's a a cube is six windows
without the pain a really good example
of this is a program
i use called blender which is i mean
there's a lot of them it's 3d
it's basically 3d paint i think there's
a such thing as 3d paint even but yeah
essentially
it's paint but in 3d and there you have
a goodies good
a really good idea of what they're doing
which is which is using a bunch of
locations but this is really more for
programming
like obviously if you're making a if you
if you wanted to make a
die for example a six-sided guy in this
program you wouldn't need all the stuff
inside because wherever you're going to
use this
the viewer is never going to see the
inside of this die
yeah but this part of the movie is the
die like splitting in half then you have
to do those two sides as well
but remember like in in a computer
program
you can say well this cube hit against
that cube or against the cylinder
against the
pyramid or whatever three you know 3d
against 3d you don't need the insides
but if all you're talking about is
locations because that's how you
programmed it right what is colliding
are we colliding locations a set of
locations here
with a set of location here well you can
do that in a computer yeah but not in
physics
and that's the issue the issue is you
can't do that in physics and you say
well how important is that well let me
tell you
why it's important uh at the at cern
at the large hadron collider at slack
at fermi lab what they do is collide
what
wave functions that's what they collide
they're colliding wave functions
but that's the other and you're saying
wow
well it's all the same thing it's an
equation it's an abstraction
and they're saying we're accelerating
what do you mean you're accelerating
what are you accelerating what we're
accelerating
energy what do you mean accelerate what
is energy it's
a concept but in the program you can
define what a collision is basically
when two
uh the surfaces of two objects that you
put in there
share the same location 3d location but
if you have like if you have objects
yeah yeah but in real life you can't
really know
if they have the same thing and i think
that's the you can't do that with a
formula
what location does the number three have
yeah but i mean
that's that's the point i'm trying to
make in computers you can do a lot of
stuff because it's all
abstract you can play around with that
and that's good i mean if you want to
play but it's how logical is the point
yeah but it's not logical when you
go into the lab and say okay now can we
do what you did with your computer
program can we do that in the lab and
the answer is no you can't
have locations hit locations you can
program that in the computer and you can
put some image there
and play or you can even have them go
right through each other you can do
whatever you want
but you can't do that out there in the
lab that's my point okay you can't do it
with physical things you can imagine it
but you can't do it okay and that's one
of the issues that
that's why we can't say that an object
is that which we can touch or see
because there are objects computer
objects i guess you call them
objects yeah you can't see or touch okay
so what's the issue with that well uh in
general relativity they extrapolate
all this stuff onto uh space time you
know space time is considered a four
dimensional
entity stuff thing whatever you want to
call it
okay and so this is a quick summary of
this
no figures in mathematical physics and
geometry and therefore
mathematical physics which is founded on
these are the foundations mathematical
physics
has irrational foundations oh i hate
that net that goes down when they when
they
try to visualize gravity i'm like okay
they're just using gravity to pull
gravity down
yeah there you see it spacetime is
alleged to be a geometric theory of
gravity what does that mean it means
that
you distort the fabric called
fabric you know again it's like saying
the the
uh what is it yarn yeah but it's not
that's i think
it's always a quote unquote
representation yeah and so
they're pulling it down yeah but even a
child can be like okay but you're using
gravity to pull the gravity down
and besides the fact that what do you
mean marbles rolling around
on gravity you don't see that in a
second yeah illustrate it
anyway it says to the space time space
versus time right
uh weighing canvas downwards invokes
newtonian gravitational force
which is what you see there 3d space
time time flowing and
dragging objects towards the earth's
center also invokes force
but is not a geometric explanation this
is not geometry when they do that
what they're saying is the mechanism is
not really geometry the mechanism
is newtonian force you use the
newtonian force uh not the the force
equals mass times acceleration but
force equals gravitational constant g
mass mass divided by distance squared
that's the equation used in that case
okay
okay and then space time is an
irrational mathematical concept
why because you're taking space which is
nothing
but even assuming space for something
let's concede that
time fortunately and i hope everybody
realizes is a concept you can't say time
is a physical object
you know what does it look like and so
you can't merge even if
space was a thing you cannot merge it
with time and say i'm going to bend time
or
space time so that's an irrational
concept that's what they do
it is irrational to propose that mass or
gravity can bend
the concept time time time quote unquote
merely being a concept
is is a whole topic on its own yeah
wrapping your head around that one
time is a weird one and the issue the
issue there is that
uh mathematical physics has no physical
interpretation
so they had to use these i don't even
know what to call them they're
they're not even analogies analogies of
what but they use these
physical interpretations and when you
say but that's irrational they say oh
but that's
that's philosophy anyways yeah then why
physics is math but then why'd you try
anyway yeah
that's that's the part that bothers me
is like why do they even try to give it
physical representations if that's not
their job
and this is what they come up with this
is this is what they end up with
okay yeah of time okay
if this is true if we're rolling around
we'd be crushed
australia will be gone yeah and you can
see the moon doesn't fly out of the
sun or the earth you know either one out
of the solar system it's another one
where's the sun on this wouldn't that be
pulling the canvas even lower
yeah yeah it does a dumb thing and so uh
the issue here is that
they say that's warped time and it's a
canvas
it's a physical object that comes
against the surface of the moon
and that's why the moon doesn't fly out
of the solar system or the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system there's this
warped fabric that
is made of time and the earth the skin
of the earth is
pushing up against it that's the
physical interpretation
and they say well you shouldn't take it
literally what do you mean
i need to explain why the earth doesn't
fly out of the solar system
what do you mean i can't take it
literally yeah i have to take it i mean
it's a nice start it's like it's a nice
theory like okay you think about a bit
what about that what about that you
start breaking it down it's much easier
to do with ropes
yeah yeah swinging i mean it gets
complicated when you try to put them all
together that's for sure
here it is here's the mechanism yeah but
it's not just that it's also one
pulling that one around pulling your
hand around there's one
pulling my hand around they're all just
flying around each other basically
it gets nice but okay i'm going to get
to some of the questions people ask and
i'm going to
go to the questions that people ask
today okay i got to give these guys
priority because they
they put questions in the videos and so
uh we try to answer those first here
okay here goes the first one fella says
okay physics doesn't have dimensions or
coordinates
that is exclusively the domain of
mathematics
dimensions are literally counting this
is what he says it's counting dimensions
has to do
accounting one of the guys that ask this
question
dimensions are so you can know how many
dials you need to understand the state
of a system
for examples we have three separate
dials in your car to measure your speed
the amount of fuels you have left and
the rpm of your engine are those
are those dimensions okay and here let
me
give you a little uh definition from the
wikipedia which is the same by the way
is
everywhere else okay so it's not like um
like uh i'm pulling uh something that's
not
out there you know in just about every
blog or website okay
and this is what uh wikipedia says is a
dimension
this is the definition dimension of
mathematical
mathematical sorry space or object
is informally defined as the minimum
number of coordinates
needed to specify any point within it
minimum number yeah minimum number of
numbers because the coordinate if you
look up coordinate it's a number well
hold on
so according to this if you had a 2d
plane
then you'd only need two coordinates to
locate a point
within it that's that's their notion
okay that's their notion you need two
coordinates to locate
a point then and that plane that
whatever you got is two dimensional that
surface or
that uh figure you can say okay close no
it's not
not at all and we'll see in a second
okay and uh because
they have these definitions you have
this fella his name is timothy
guyan and he's uh writing in sabine
hassemfelder's
website and he puts he wrote an article
and this is the informal
version of that same article known as
problems with
eric weinstein's geometric unity
what does uh eric weinstein propose he's
a
popular hancho out there mathematical
hancho
he says gu meaning the geometry
of geometric unity asserts that there is
a set of what
equations in 14 dimensions that are to
contain
the einstein dirac and yang mills
equations that's the minimum
yeah i mean uh so what the hell are they
talking about what do you mean
what the hell are they telling what do
you mean 14 dimension and you can see
that everybody
in mathematics right in the religion of
mathematics
uses it like this fellow he says uh i
look at everything in my car
and each one of those gauges that's a
dimension one tells me
what the rpm is the other one how much
gas i have you know those are dimensions
it is my number properties yeah i mean
that's like wait that's why they come up
with infinite dimensions
because they they never defined the word
dimension property if you had three
bananas on a table
you can't say that three banana the
quantity of bananas on the table is a
dimension just because the number
property
let me even put it worse what did the
wikipedia say
three coordinates to locate a point yeah
that gives its
three-dimensional if it's two
coordinates then it's two-dimensional
minimum okay how many how many how many
coordinates do i need to locate
rpm on a surface of a of a plane or
at a sphere i mean one one definition
has nothing to do with how this fall
used it
i mean temperature how many how many
numbers do i need to locate
temperature on the surface of a cube
right
yeah that doesn't make sense i mean what
they're saying the use they're giving it
has nothing to do with the definition
with a formal definition of the word
dimension
this is where where they go wrong they
don't even f they define something then
they don't use it they use something
else
whatever notion they're using who has
who knows and we don't do that in
science and science we're consistent
because otherwise we end up
uh being crazy yeah like these fellows
say
and this is what we how we define it in
science
okay first uh this is out of my book
why god doesn't exist one of three
mutually orthogonal directions in which
an object may
face or point okay i missed that one you
don't like the word point
yeah yeah you can be misconstrued
yeah you're right no point in that one
of the three lines or edges that forms a
vortex
or corner okay the three dimensions of
physics are called what
length width and height those are the
ones we use in physics because we're
talking about objects
we don't know anything about this
locating a
a point within a sphere you require two
or three
coordinates dimensions have absolutely
nothing to do with coordinates and there
you see it what are dimensions length
with a knight
because we're looking at how an object
is pointing we're looking at orientation
with respect to a given
rough frame of reference what is the
coordinate it's the location of
something
from three uh locations in this case
from a cube we're trying to locate a box
inside a cube
well you need three coordinates to
locate three what perpendicular
directions okay and they're coordinates
they're not numbers
they're just directions they don't have
magnitude they just have
direction and orthogonality
perpendicularity
okay that's what they have and um so i
put there
three dimensions length within height
dimensions shouldn't under no
circumstances be confused with
coordinates which is what the
mathematicians do all the time
which are what longitude latitude and
altitude and what are
vectors vectors have to do with motion
not with location
death breath and elevation now we can
understand and use it consistently
and that's not what these people can do
can you talk about coordinates without
numbers
it seems weird yeah because people say
well what is the use for this
and we have no use in mathematics for
this of course not
because these are qualitative concepts
in any context
is there a point of talking about
coordinates if you're not going to give
numbers like coordinates without actual
numbers
no you don't need numbers because all
you're saying is that this
object is located with respect to the
tree to the house and to the right
okay it's a qualitative location it's
it's got to do with distance but not
distance in numbers it's got to do with
this
or for example distance traveled it's
got to do with separation
it's all qualitative there's no number
involved here no no
magnitude in fact here we have mr
stephen hawking
stephen gawking that's a block of text
and yeah it's a
bunch here but it's uh interesting if
you read it i'll leave it there for a
second so that you can
cover it later on but essentially he's
saying you know uh he's saying that
you need four coordinates to uh locate
an event
and he's saying he can use anything he
wants he says he can use time
as a as a dimension hold on that doesn't
make sense if you have
if i give you if as the four dimensions
i gave you temperature
weight yeah time and height you can't
locate that [ __ ]
yeah and this is the problem you know in
fact
he he he makes an error here let's see
if i can find it
uh let me see
where is it uh yeah i think it's here
uh yeah see in the first paragraph uh
the last
sentence or one could specify that a
point was a
certain what latitude and longitude
and certain height above sea level
height
is a dimension latitude and longitude
are coordinates
he's using him interchangeably he
doesn't have i mean here you have a phd
he's gone now but he he was a phd a guru
in mathematics
you know mathematical physics and he
doesn't know the difference between a
coordinated dimension he mixes height
which is really altitude it's like when
people confuse
um light light years with time
yeah yeah it's a distance
and uh and so he does this all the time
and he says that you can use the time
dimension
and replace uh one of the height or or
one of the space as he calls space
dimensions like
height or width or length you can
replace it with time
then they have these space-time diagrams
where they get rid of two of the
dimensions they only have one
again remember the dimensions require
orthogonality you can't get rid of the
other two
i know you like to get rid of them to do
your math stuff you can't get rid of
them in physics physics requires three
dimensions if you're going to talk about
dimension
because it contains two properties one
is direction
which you cannot chop into units that
means you cannot put magnitudes
to direction direction is a solid piece
it's a made of a single piece
distance and direction you can't chop
direction
it's irrational and these people chop
direction put units in there and they
say oh we have a dimension which is a
coordinate which is a vector it's all
the same to them
and then they say time is one so what
sense does it all make
yeah that's why they lose track and they
talk about four dimensional objects like
because they lost track of all that yeah
they abandoned logic
this was the second part of that also
from uh why god doesn't exist let me put
over here
i'll cover your face if you don't uh in
science dimensions are static concepts
okay
they have two properties direction and
orthogonality
there is no such thing as a dimension
without the other two
you need three you can't do it with
three you can use two but
the other one is is is there yeah yeah
you can't just talk about two dimensions
you you can i mean you can talk but the
other one is there
hitting the weight he's it's implied
right
there is no such thing as dimension
without the other two whenever we talk
about with we are implicitly alluding to
length and height in the religion of
mathematics dimensions are treated as
dynamic concepts
that's the problem because they're
numbers okay which is counting
yeah which is what this file said the
dimensions of mathematics have magnitude
but
lack direction or orthogonal direction
conceptually static
and made of a single piece okay
directions made of a single piece
continues
the dimensions of math are segmented
meaning that they are composed of
countless
numbers you cannot reconcile segmented
with direction okay direction is made of
a single piece conceptually
okay and so you can't say you're going
to chop direction in
little magnitudes little pieces that's
why
the uh mathematicians are really talking
about number lines and that's why
they say well i can put the number line
called time and replace the one called
length which are
talking about distance traveled uh in a
certain direction so they say well i can
chop that into numbers i can say it's
all
qualitative yeah because they say i can
travel one mile two miles three miles
i'll put a little x for each one of the
miles
i can travel one minute two minutes
three minutes right and then i can say
well i can
replace that with time because instead
of using miles i'll say
seconds or minutes or hours you know
that it took me to travel those
and so that's why they can replace it
back and forth what are they talking
about they're talking about
uh um not coordinates not dimensions not
vert
vectors vectors they're talking about
number lines i mean a good example
in a formula is meters per second
they're just
numbers yeah they're interchangeable if
you put it on the equation
you can they're just numbers that you
can switch out for each other but meters
and seconds
are qualitatively different and the
important thing about that is that
number lines do not
have direction they and they don't have
orthogonality they don't stan
you know time doesn't travel either
forward it goes that way
yeah mine goes that way time doesn't
travel forward
because they're talking about time when
they say forward they're not talking
about a direction
and time you can chop into pieces
because you can talk about seconds
minutes or hours
but time does not have direction or
orthogonality to anything because it
doesn't have direction
what's orthogonality exactly uh
perpendicularity that is perpendicular
to something else
so you you cannot have that okay
okay let's continue here another fellow
who raises another issue
he says a belief can be true or false
uh well uh that those are opinions right
belief are opinions so
they can be true or false or neither i
guess maybe
hypothesis is defined as a justified
belief that is not known to be true
well it's true by whom what do you mean
it's a belief
you mean a hypothesis is a belief an
assumption is a belief
jesus thus a hypothesis is a belief that
is backed up with some supporting
evidence observation experiment but it
may still be
false what have you said you denied your
statement
wait it still may be false yeah if it's
false then who cares if your belief is
false
and false by whose standard by the pope
standard by the dalai lama i mean who's
saying that it's false
i mean do we vote we say we raise our
hands say well we voted
50 plus one and we said it's false
that's usually how it works
i mean what the hell is that a theory is
a substantiated explanation for an
occurrence
that has come to a conclusion listen to
this
a judgment or decision reached by
reasoning consistent repeatable
observations and experiment
though not unimpeachable so you just
destroyed your argument
you contain your own destruction does it
mean come to a conclusion well on the
one hand he says it's a substantiated
statement because we have the
observation the experiment the
repeatability whatever
and he said no it's not unimpeachable
what have we learned we have learned but
it might not be yeah it might not be
yeah we proved it uh with experiment
with observation we all agree upon
but it could be a could be wrong it
could be that the earth is not flat
so what have we what have we learned
i mean these definitions okay
invisible intangible physical object
mechanism
double row single thread is a belief no
it's an assumption
assumption is not a belief it's because
you defined it as a belief that's why
uh you get trapped in your own belief
what's the difference between belief and
assumption real quick
uh we'll get to that in a second because
i'm going to get to that now this is a
perfect time
let's see if we can get that unless i
think it's the next one here ah
hypothesis this is this is what an
assumption
is okay this is the scientific method
let me let me put it over here
this is the scientific method the true
genuine scientific method why because
it's used for what for
rational explanations which is what
science
is okay and the scientific method starts
with a hypothesis it's a way of
explaining
something to someone else sometimes to
yourself okay it already happened
yeah and you're going to explain
something that already happened
a consummated event and what do we have
well we have
first you got to present the objects
because you're going to explain a
mechanism
okay and you have to have definitions
and then you have the initial scene
and nowhere do you see the word
observation in there okay there's no
room for observation or experiments you
just have to
give uh you just have to give an
explanation for
a uh an event a phenomenon did you have
to see it did you have to observe it did
you have to
run an experiment no not at all someone
could have told you about it
uh you didn't even see it or run an
experiment to prove your
theory or whatever you just come to the
uh conference and say look
uh here are the objects here's the
definitions this is what i'm going to
explain
okay and then you explain it explain the
mechanism the reason for that is because
if we're just going to use
logic then we just need to know
if a fault if b follows from a so we
don't really need to know the
the details like like if this is true or
whatever or if
it's been observed right it's just
premises
yeah exactly just premises we're just
using logic then then we just need to
know what what the logic
is right what relates to what and then
the other issue
which is with this file says absolute
last statement there absolutely no
supporting evidence in observation
and no supporting experimentation again
you don't need any observation
experimentation or supporting evidence
what is evidence
evidence is what the prosecutor and uh
religion the pope uses to try to
convince you to believe in his
religion oh we don't need evidence in
science no we don't need evidence in
science
uh in science evidence is religion
evidence means you're going to
convince the jury that the person is
guilty so sorry and then half of the
other people believe he's innocent and
so uh
it comes down to belief so for real real
quick if i wanted to explain
the sun going around the um the earth
going around the sun
and try to use angels i don't need to
any evidence about the angels no you
don't need any evidence because the only
issue is
explain to us your mechanism what is it
you have going through your mind and you
say okay
look the earth goes around the sun i'm
going to make that assumption i'm going
to make the assumptions round also
whatever you know you may use something
usually when we're talking about
assumptions we're talking about the
things that we don't
usually yeah like the one the things
that we don't take for granted did i
ever observe the earth going around the
sun
absolutely not except in pictures and
movies etc i've never gone out there and
actually seen the earthquake around the
sun and even if you did you might be
drunk
yeah exactly and so i'm just going to
make an assumption i'm going to make an
assumption my assumptions the earth goes
around the sun okay
and now i'm going to explain how it does
assuming it does i'll put it
and so now okay an angel pushes no no no
hold on
you got to go step by step you got guys
say let me propose the
objects that are going to intervene in
my theory and the first one is an angel
i'm going to put an angel an angel is
not a concept
an angel is an object it's a guy with
wings exactly
a guy with wings sent by god or whoever
i i can draw an angel it's got shape and
that's what an object is it's
it's an object that has you know an
object because it
has shape so an angel is an object it's
not a concept
okay so we have the angel he's got two
hands he's gonna push the earth around
he's a big angel okay he's bigger than
the earth
he flies his wings i don't know why
because you don't need them in space but
that's my theory so i get away with it
not theory hypothesis
uh no no now i'm going to explain the
theory i'm going to say well
i present the objects i'm saying this is
an angel he's got wings he can fly those
are the
assumptions yeah now i'm going to say
the theory the theory is that the reason
the earth goes around the sun
is that an angel is pushing the earth
and while he does it he twirls it around
he thinks his finger
okay okay so that's my theory
now the question is did you understand
my theory
i'm not asking you so far i haven't
answered what i mean by
understand did you understand my theory
again it depends on
what you mean by that because because i
i understand how superficial though but
if you dig deeper you used to okay i
don't understand
this angel guy specifically no no i'm
not asking you to understand the angel
guy
right now you know that's hard to
understand well you can always get to
that later on i'm just asking you to
understand the mechanism
right now we're trying to understand
them yeah but but again it depends on
what we're talking about
like it depends on how deep you want to
understand devil's advocate
oh no but seriously if someone says do
you understand how the light turned on
yeah i flipped the switch on well that's
not what
but did you use it i don't know but it
because that's not what i meant did you
understand how the electricity turning
on the light
happened so yeah which
again you can go deeper and deeper my
point here is that you understand the
general theory of what i'm saying i'm
saying
the reason the earth goes around the sun
there's a this object called an angel
flapping his wings that move moves the
earth around the sun and you say
well but that's not science that's
religion that
did you understand my theory that's what
i believe in fine or maybe i don't
believe in it
doesn't matter i'm explaining to you a
mechanism did you understand the
mechanism
if you understood the mechanism we're
done with science with the explanation
now we go into belief religion did you
believe it no i didn't
no that's it for that but that's the
issue the issue is how you explain the
theory
has nothing to do with whether you
believe in it that's where we draw a
line
and right now people don't understand
that because they think it's got to do
with evidence
we're running an experiment with uh
convincing the jury
you know it's with observation well i
think those are those are all subjective
those have to do with religion i think
when we're talking about science
yeah we want to we're talking we're
essentially trying to
to figure out how the universe works
yeah but it's still a belief issue
not not not how to explain it but
essentially we're trying to
justify our beliefs or trying to figure
out like again if i want to know
how a magnet works basically i'm
investigating so that my belief so i can
believe
something that makes sense you believe
but i don't say no no what i mean is is
that
the the that's the word the purpose the
purpose of science is to
save to straighten out your beliefs no
no it's not why else would no
no no why would you want to know how to
explain to have all the explanations in
front of us
and everybody can choose whichever one
they want but that's the point
the the whole point of physics is that
yeah yeah but there's no no
no no no no the last step is religion
yeah but that's
religion is the point of physics that's
the point of physics
no no we have to separate religion from
science science stops
stops that's where that's the stopping
point
but not the stopping or understanding
but that's not the stopping point of the
purpose of science
the purpose of science is to understand
not to believe
i guess but it's explaining the question
begins why do you want to understand
just just let us know so that i have the
right
i want to have the correct belief no
because your correct belief is my
incorrect belief
i don't know but i want something i
believe the guy what the big guy knows
okay let's continue here uh fellow
continues
yeah i know so we gotta hurry here uh
this says observation
uh experiment is data collection often
ending and making correct predictions
predictions what do you mean correct
prediction how many times you have to be
correct though once
and that's enough yeah i make a no
here's a prediction uh you need a pencil
here
we'll make a prediction here we're gonna
let go of the pencil let me
take this out for a second so they can
see and we've seen this one before
yeah yeah let's go with a pencil i can
make a prediction that's gonna fall down
on the table but it turns out i do it
100 times always falls to the table i'll
make a new prediction i'll say 101 time
it'll fall to the table i know for sure
it turns out it stands in the air did i
show you that one
and why because magicians did i show you
that one there's
the pen and teller where they're doing a
whole bunch of tricks
and it turns out that the whole thing
was filmed upside down
upside down so the things start falling
you know up yeah and so
people say oh how did that happen well
because they filmed it upside down
that's
or turned the film around but uh there's
all kinds of tricks you can put a magnet
to hold the
pencil in the uh in the air maybe it's
got a
metal you know lead point
uh maybe you draw it with air from above
there's all kinds of tricks you can do
to
get that pencil to stay in the air and
you say hey
uh your your prediction came out wrong
well
i don't know what happened here well
yeah i can do all kinds of tricks and
make your prediction come out wrong
you know you say your horse is going to
win what's the point of the obstacle
well he says he says that you know you
need
observation to make prediction correct
predictions data click
often ending in making correct
predictions
uh let me give you uh an example let me
give you let me give you another
example you know you got the gravity
probe b
was run by nasa okay so they sent the
probe out there into the gyroscopes
couple gyroscopes that
took them a long time to make perfect
almost they sent it out there
and they said okay we we proved
we predicted that this was going to
happen because einstein's theory
einstein's equation says so and they
their prediction came out right the
gyroscopes moved in the way they
claimed that it would move they had a
prediction
what was the prediction the prediction
or the result was that
they proved that space that time
is a physical object right that's that's
what they proved
they said that the gyroscopes rubbed
their elbows or whatever their skin
against uh space time meaning time time
itself
so that's what they proved is that a
good prediction i mean
what kind of nonsense is that you know
so
so all this stuff about prediction has
nothing to do with science
science we explain we don't do
predictions it's kind of like you talked
about with the pen
yeah i mean not even fools it's not
about that it's
if you drop a pen that doesn't tell you
what happened yeah we need to know
even if you predict it'll happen it
doesn't mean you know it'll happen i
said that the other day
and i can predict that there's going to
be an eclipse tomorrow at five o'clock
in the afternoon
that doesn't mean i can explain why it's
going to happen i just observed over
time that
every year or every 10 years on such and
such
time there's an eclipse i don't know why
but it happens
i just keep track of time or i read
history and found out that other people
tracked it over time and i say case in
point haley's comment
haiti's comment was discovered like that
was discovered exactly like that they
said
uh you know haley he came up he finally
looked at the
record in the past he said look every 76
years 75 76 years
this this comment comes down he says i
can predict it's going to come again
he doesn't know how it flies he doesn't
know why it comes maybe an angel's
pushing it
all he knows it's going to come every 76
years that's it i know the mailman is
going to come tomorrow
you know what he drives do you know what
he's doing i know why because i sent the
letter to myself
so he's gonna come tomorrow yeah it's
that sort of thing
he said something else here he said uh
what
oh my god it goes on the other side
okay here it is he said uh how to hell
uh can you immediately jump to a belief
or hypothesis without having made an
observation
well because a hypothesis is not a
belief and a belief is not a hypothesis
hypothesis includes the objects
definitions and the initial scene
that you're going to later on explain
through a theory
okay okay a couple more questions then
we'll get to the questions today
uh let's hurry up here we're we're
falling behind today yeah we're going
we're we're having fun today
believes objects is that which shape
believes love is a concept
well yeah because it's not that we
believe it's that
we define we define what an object is we
define what a concept is and then it
follows from the definitions
okay so you got to define these words
before you can make those statements
before you can criticize
okay you got to define object and
concept then we'll know if love is a
concept
and whether you know uh i don't know a
tree is an object
another comment made by a fellow
says between two atoms uh rope
his english was not too good but uh we
can get there
rope never bend according to your
assumption but in your
mechanism of magnet you show the rope
spin that means
rope should bend otherwise it's not spin
it's rotate
my point is how is this possible to
explain mechanism of magnet
is spinning rope when your assumption is
rope never bend between
two atoms in other words he's saying why
does the rope bend when we do
magnetism it's not the rope that bends
okay so here i have it illustrated so
that the person sees it
okay let me make this a little bigger
here okay
what spins are threads not rope
rope and thread are two different things
the rope is made
of two threads when the uh sequence of
atoms spin they spin the threads that
either serve as a rope between them or
the make up the shells the
electron shells the membranes that are
also made of threads
so when they spin they're spinning all
these threads around themselves it's not
the rope that is spinning it's a thread
so the thread is curved the rope is
always not straight it's known as
it's tight tightly pulled by adam why
because
every atom in the universe is pulling on
our two atoms
from everywhere and so that thing is as
tight as it can be
okay that's what it is what all they can
do is slide
along the ropes because they as the atom
slides you know the
rope goes around the electron which
criteria do you use to like choose these
questions or where do you get them from
no that makes you pick one over another
no something that needs to be clarified
that's essentially
it you know no more than that okay
another fellow here he asks uh
he says why stuff like quantum mechanics
is way more convincing than the rope
model
the rope model is simple and plain
whereas the quantum model is vague
with a strong frame yeah i kind of agree
with you okay
when someone says something like zero
dimension or transcendence
they are always imagining some kind of
object and yeah that's true
uh i think uh the majority of people in
the world
are not rational and that's why the
majority of people of the world
are religious they believe in some kind
of magic
you know they invoke gods and spirits
and
you know what moved the curtain well i
think it was uh
i think it was the spirit of my
great-grandmother
and that's what they believe and that's
why belief
should not form part of science it
should be part of religion
the word belief opinion you know
anything that's subjective
that belongs to religion in science we
got to be strictly
objective and as long as we're there we
won't get hurt
we'll understand and whether you believe
what the guy just explained that's your
personal
bias belief is a separate issue that
is outside the bounds of science okay
a couple more here you can get them here
uh you talk about immanuel kant uh you
should talk about emmanuel can
rational science seems to the
to be derived from kantian idealism
please explain why it isn't
well uh the problem with kent
kant as known in german um
he he he was a metaphysical guy and
metaphysics
is nonsense pure nonsense supernatural
no it's not it's not supernatural what
metaphysical
is is that it it kind of blends
so-called philosophy with physics they
get into ontology
what what do you mean by exist and what
is an object
they get into those questions those
questions do not belong to philosophy
those
questions are strictly within the bounds
of physics physics is the discipline
that
deals with what an object is because
physics cannot be done with objects
with without objects and it it is the
science of existence
physics only deals with that which
exists but i don't understand
what is metaphysics metaphysics okay we
gotta get into
the question uh
aristotle uh his book is called
metaphysics he's got a book called
physics and another one called
metaphysics what is metaphysics
according to that book okay because he
invented the word or
the greeks did and he just used it
metaphysics means
what comes after physics and that's why
people
uh say well that's philosophy it's like
okay let's ponder what we just did
like so the phys well it's like the
physics is
here's the explanation of uh metaphysics
why are we talking about this at all
yeah yeah it's like it's like
it's just a description because that's
essentially what it comes down to if you
look at aristotle he tried to explain
but
he did it with a lot of descriptions and
that's not an explanation a bunch of
descriptions do not amount to an
explanation
and and then he said when he finished
that book he says okay now let's think
about what we did and then
what are we going to call the we call it
after physics metaphysics like
we go to the bar now we get a beer and
we [ __ ] the bull
at the water cooler and let's think
about what we just did what we
talked about and so it's what comes
after physics and that's why
they say it's part of philosophy it's
the philosophy of science
not science itself that's what the
mainstream believes out there okay
that's that's the context
anyways uh this uh kant he was
a metaphysicist you can say and the
problem with
everything that kant did and everyone
that came after okay
until we come along is they um
they introduce uh the observer and when
you introduce the observer you're
introducing
subjectivity science kills the observer
there are no observers in science it's
all objective
explanation just explain the mechanism
i'll tell you if i believe in it or not
tomorrow right now i just want to
understand
what your mechanism is that's the
difference
and as long as we keep it like that we
know the difference between science and
religion
okay and uh final word
uh final question fellow brings in a
flat earth uh
thing he said uh i just found this video
and i noticed a lot of science in it a
lot of explanations yes they use plenty
of religion
as they indoctrinate they're
indoctrinated to believe that proof and
evidence are part of science
they haven't found you yet however i
feel that there were plenty of
explanations that didn't involve
any religion i really hope to hear you
talk about their content
well the video is called level 2021
okay level uh meaning flat right
flat earthers i didn't look at the whole
video it was like an hour plus
long and so what i did was i just uh
went to
like six or seven parts throughout the
video to see if it was worth my time
it wasn't worth my time because every
one of the seven places where i went
it was all conspiracy that's why i got
that little spy there
it's all conspiracy it's like oh they're
keeping information away from us they're
misleading us you know it wasn't worth
anything
science is not about conspiracies
okay conspiracy is assuming that if
we're flat then what would we
be looking for right this is the context
of the flat earth i have no problem with
people coming saying look i believe in
the flat earth great i don't care if you
believe or not
what do you explain with a flat earth
please explain gravity with
the flat earth model for example
tell me how gravity works show me or
whatever you want uh you know
gravity maybe magnetism whatever you
want no problem
don't tell me the earth is flat and i
believe in it i don't care about any of
that because
that's your assumption that is an
assumption right it's just an assumption
it's like saying let us assume god
exists okay god exists
i'll concede the assumption and let me
show you how god created the universe
so let me show you the mechanism fine
then we have a theory of science
uh up to a certain point
in the sense that i just want to
understand it i want to understand what
what your theory what you got going
through your mind
once i understand it we're done with you
can say the science part there could be
a lot of questions
if you're satisfied with your
understanding because those different
levels of understanding yeah i'm
satisfied at this low but if you want to
like take a little bit exactly okay but
exactly how flat do we move my flat
where's the sun where's the moon all
that stuff
the issue with the flat earth is the the
same thing uh
you make an assumption you say let us
assume the earth is flat fine no problem
now what are you going to explain with
that
well that's they do it the other way
around they they they
take other things as assumptions to
explain why the earth is
yeah i know they get to the conclusion
that's one issue the other one is it's
just
conspiracies they they're keeping the
information away from us they know it's
flat but they don't want us to know it
for whatever reason yeah yeah
okay let's get to the questions today
now uh i'll take over you'll take over
let's see what we got today although i
still think it'd be cooler to like
read these as we go but i don't know
that's kind of the fun of it well let's
find out here oh
[ __ ] uh i mean as i was laughing reading
you're eating
okay i'll let you read them yeah
even if food were unlimited talking
about extinction
yeah yeah uh we would still go
extinct due to genetics anyways uh yeah
i would think uh
one of the issues we discussed with this
gentleman today
is aging you know and
we all i'm aging for sure i'm getting
close to 70
we're all aging right and we all die
because after a while you know we a
don't age no more but this is the
million dollar question
okay do species age
and the answer the quick one for this
fellow here
is that unless we die in a mass
extinction which is a food related
mechanism we die of uh
old age a species dies of old age that's
the
mechanism of a background extinction
what is old age two things
first you lose your genetic diversity
over time you may well clones
uh yeah eventually you end up you get
this clonification
process one issue and the other one is
at the end of the process
you have this overturning of the
population pyramids so we get a double
whammy
we get the overturning of the population
pyramid i've explained that in the past
and then you also get right at the same
time because of that you get
also a whittling down of our genetic
diversity so those two mechanisms
ensure that the species is old and is
about to die you also have
examples not of us but of
species who've gone extinct in the past
you have examples of mass extinctions
and you have examples of backgrounds and
distinctions so there's two mechanisms
and willie died willie died because of
that mechanic he didn't die in a massive
extinction he died although he smelled
like a guy
willie oh willie lives across the street
willie mammoth yeah the willie mammoth
and uh neanderthal they died both in a
background extinction in other words
they died all alone
in fact that it's so strange that
neanderthal died before wooly
you know willie died uh twenty thousand
years later
yeah willie mammoth uh i called willie
the woolies
uh and and they died uh all alone they
died why because they're
not because their food ran out they died
of old age the species died of old age
one garlic head costs over one dollar in
poland the end is near
[Laughter]
we got a few questions from our buddy
lambert here uh how do ropes make
the poisson spot in fresnel diffraction
next thanks i'm curious about that um
hopefully a rational question
it's not how you make something a lot of
them are comments which are more
poignant in the moment yeah but you know
the problem is we read them all at the
end well no problem we can still
go backwards will people work for free
supply gas for free
no people won't work for free they might
work for food but not for free
i can't imagine anyone working for feet
but i see a lot of people with the signs
you know saying we'll work for food
uh is there a chance to see you in a
famous talk show or podcast
such as world science festival debunking
all the phony baloney
about time dark matter black holes and
all the circus tales
well sometimes i'm invited sometimes i
go sometimes i don't you know they're
it's a possibility yeah would you be
respectful if you were the writers
uh usually i'm respectful but
not when when i'm running my show i'm
not respectful but
in fact it's the other way around i'm
very respectful
i treat them with a respect that they
deserve that's the way we put it okay
we treat it with a respect i mean if a
guy tells you that a particle can be at
two places at once
or that the universe came out of big
bang you call him an idiot
that's when i come in okay let's go
you're not insulting them you're you're
just using the word in the dictionary
appropriate for that
individual you say that uh you treat him
with the respect that he deserves
but yeah when i'm usually in other
places i don't
go into i don't treat them with their
respect that they need
is it accurate to say concepts help us
think about physical objects
and that people confuse the physical
with the way we think about them
uh yeah but remember concept is uh you
gotta define the word concept first and
that's uh
a word that invokes two objects okay
that's the definition we have here
and then uh referring to your question
yeah
you can say that people look at objects
and immediately
because we have this fantastic brain
that god or whoever the devil gave us
we immediately see more into it than we
enter in this subjective mode
where we see more into it than is there
between the lines
it's uh what we just saw a minute ago
with the tesseract you look at a
tesseract what do you see in front of
you two nested cubes
period i mean you're you're looking at
that as two
it's a three-dimensional projection onto
a two-dimensional platform right so you
say well it's two nested cubes
that's what's objectively in front of
you that's what a point is a circle you
know a little circle that's
a dot that's what's objectively in front
of you
is that what people see they say no
that's a location what do you mean
okay i see a dot i see a little a smudge
uh a spot
and they say no no see it represents
it's a pictorial representation of a
location
so we take it already into the
subjective mode
of what's not in front of us in fact we
conceptify things so quickly and so
off hand that there's this one character
in a show who is he's like an alien
and his species is incapable of metaphor
they speak only in literal terms and
when you listen to it it's
really weird like he makes you laugh
like you're not
you're not used to it because but that's
weird because you think that the way
the things you literally see is the way
we treat the world but no we
we add so many layers of concepts like
this is just a cup
but it's not even a cup it's it's
plastic
it's plastic in a certain shape but then
we give it so many different it's red
it's this it's that and it's got this
much hardness we add so much to it
now and the other thing that you should
consider when about that subject
is that we're in the age of services
especially in abstract services such as
internet
right services and so we're getting into
such
abstract uh modes for example bitcoins
i mean how abstract can money get and so
we're in this world of abstractions we
have movies we have
so much stuff on the internet it's all
abstract
that we become more subjective than
objective
we've stopped being objective in many
cases a lion
is objective i mean any animal out there
for that matter
they look and they see oh that's food
i'm going to hunt it i'm going to kill
them not
necessarily because but they're more on
this track
they don't think beyond uh they have to
know it at some level they have to know
where
to hunt like not that they put it into
words but like they have they they have
their own concepts
yeah but it's in lion version it's not
okay but the guy knows when when he
smells smells
somebody like his piss on the tree he's
like okay this has this territory of
someone else he doesn't put it in those
turns but like there is something okay
there is some level
yeah i mean the guy is but ours is
ridiculous
yeah i mean we've taken it to such uh
levels that it's unbelievable
in fact i once told you the hardest part
about physics is it's strictly literal
yeah that's what makes that music so
hard like you always say it's like baby
stuff but yeah i mean it's hard
not to add concepts it's really hard
yeah i i say it's kindergarten stuff
because if as long as you're literal
uh then we can have it it's hard to stay
literal yeah but if people start going
into concepts they lose track of what
they're saying
and other people can't follow them
because you know like dimension what do
you really mean by a dimension
you defined it as this and now you're
going to use it as numbers or
temperature or rpm what the hell is that
it's hard to be robotic i guess
so we're trying to transition physics is
robotic
um
it's annoying to build way so many hours
answering questions from trolls they're
wasting your time on purpose man
no problem no problem
for lunch i mean as long as someone
learns i guess
yeah um trusty troll okay we got a troll
there
right now
but one bad thing about you boss is
sometimes i have to say something five
times until you finally understand what
the question i'm saying because you've
heard something so many times that you
instantly interpret it into your own
ways
well yeah um hey don't skip over all of
them no no
most of them are just comments okay but
you know unfortunately i'd like to read
the comment as this being said it adds
more flavor
after the fact this lady um
i think that's we don't really have that
many questions he's a materialist
arkans arkansas trout
yeah materialist uh physics is material
only
okay physics is material you gotta
explain a mechanism the only way you can
explain the mechanism
is with objects and objects is the world
of matter
what what have you encountered about
ropes in your work i don't know if this
what have you encountered about ropes in
your work i don't know if that's
to you i don't understand that question
what do you mean encounter ropes in my
no uh ropes remember one thing the rope
is
invisible intangible we say it up front
you say oh what do you mean an object
that's invisible and tangible
an object is not that which you can
touch or see it's that which has shape
so a rope has shape so it's
it's an object but it's invisible and
intentional
and so we don't encounter ropes every
day okay
it's not like well you do but you don't
notice it yeah i mean they're all over
us
and like i showed in one of my uh gifts
there
uh you know your finger is touched
is uh attached to the atoms on your
screen
by a rope that's coming perpendicular to
your finger
so when you move your finger closer to
the screen
the rope goes right through the atom so
you're sliding your
finger along the rope you can't touch
the rope because you're sliding through
it
and until you get that concept you
people say why can't you touch the rope
well you can't because you're sliding
your finger
like uh the beats on them abacus you
know you're just sliding the abacus
along the wire
you you so you can't you say why can't i
touch the light technically you're
always touching the wire
yeah but i mean in the sense that you're
sliding through it so you can't really
come against the wall and say oh i
touched the rope
that's my point you can touch another
bead but not the wire that
through which the two beads slide that's
where earlier you said the mammoths died
before the neanderthals and heroes
no no no the the mammoth is that what i
said
no i said not after so neanderthals died
before the mountains yeah yeah
wooly died uh in the uh about 12 000
years ago whereas uh
there were some woolies depending on
willie there was another one the
uh archangel
they died like four or five thousand
years ago but most of the woolies died
uh
in the uh uh what is it uh well about 12
000 years ago
and neanderthal he died about 40 000
years ago oh we have a theory
the mammoths obviously hunted the
neanderthals to extinction then
yeah that i believe
yeah because uh that was all incredible
he hunted all these things and
he went away first what's the definition
for memory
do you have a definition for memory i
remember we talked about memory in a lot
i remember once we went deep into memory
because we're talking about knowledge i
think
or the analogy with uh transistor that's
about it you know transistor
yeah yeah i mean in in the semiconductor
industry where i worked
we talked a lot about memory but you
know we put it in terms
in silicon terms uh we're talking about
you know how to
preserve memory in a little device
called the chip yeah but that's not how
it works in a transitional state i guess
but i mean i think memory in this sense
is maybe worse knowledge
well i think memory in the brain works a
lot like the memory
in a chip uh you know zeros and ones
that are stored
in terms of magnetic fields what we call
magnetic field to use
i probably don't have two gigawatts in
my brain because i forget a lot
but uh i think what it is is uh the
brain works
pretty much like um like a chip in this
sense in the sense that
uh it the memory itself is
is a flipping of the electromagnetic
threads in under the rope model and in a
certain pattern
and then when those patterns uh have a
certain relationship
with respect to each other that's when
the ideas come out because
they trigger other uh
parts of the brain to to work in a
certain way
so we're talking about like the the
origin of consciousness
it's kind of the same thing we're
talking about the origin of conscious
consciousness yeah where it's like the
the the split
or the barrier between the physical and
the mental i guess you could say
you know like how how is it that i guess
you could say two chemicals hitting each
other
ma or many obviously makes me think
about a dog
yeah i mean uh when you're talking about
you know when you talk about the brain
it's a very very complicated issue
it's a nice one well it's because it's
never talked about it at a physical
level it's always kind of like
metaphysically yeah it's like where
where do spirits come from and stuff but
yeah okay that's cool and all but on
some level you gotta talk about the
atoms right
if this item moves over there hopefully
hopefully because i think dogs
adam goes there i think cat you can't
have see some people believe there's
something called
conscious or consciousness out there
like a
soul or spirit that leaves the body goes
to heaven
or that stands separate from matter no
such monster
consciousness is a verb not a noun
and the noun that produces consciousness
are known are the
atoms and cells etc that are inside the
brain
course it's magical because we say how
is it possible that
all this matter do anything inanimate
matter that we have in our brain because
they're all atoms
ultimately how did they produce thought
yeah and that's what everybody where the
question works because we're talking
about a rock
you know you put as many rocks together
and also you have
this thing i mean life is already weird
and then you gotta answer
the question in one of two branches you
either talk about
physics about how the physical world
produces
thought okay which is very common
literal
literally yeah literally in other words
how the brain produces that that's one
issue
the other one is all this metaphysical
stuff is as it's called
where people talk about brush that real
quick yeah i don't care about this
though
not your brain it's not your brain yeah
yeah that's nonsense for me
we talk about physics we want to know
how the brain produces thought that
that's an interesting question at least
for me
from a physical standpoint you know and
i i do
i did cover that in the book as much as
i could not that i have a
an answer but uh i do try to investigate
that issue and it's a very very complex
issue
but i'm not too much into biology though
i mean you do
you find the word life yeah which
biologists don't
yeah i do a little bit of biology but
talking about it's a subject that
doesn't interest me too much regarding
using outdated examples i hope you
didn't explain to anne's how children
came from the stork model
yeah the birds and the bees i totally
said that's
we went from distort those birds in the
beach different animals
i think that's it okay well okay we'll
see you
then when uh next wednesday okay
we'll see you then bye-bye